we now have the tools i think to
understand the idea of a linear subspace
of rn let me write that down
and i'll just write it just i'll just
always call it a subspace of rn
everything we're doing is linear
subspace
subspace of rn
i'm going to make a definition here i'm
going to say that a set of vectors v
so v
is some subset of vectors
subset
some subset of
rn
rn so we already said rn when we think
about it's really just a a really an
infinitely large set of vectors where
each of those vectors have n
components so you know we i'm going to
not formally define it but this is just
a set of vectors i mean sometimes we
visualize it as multi-dimensional space
and all that but if we wanted to be just
as abstract about it as possible it's
just all the set it's the set of all of
the you know we could call it x1
x2 all the way to xn
where each of these where each of the
xi's are a member of the real numbers
for i is for all of the i's
right that was our definition of rn it's
just a huge set of vectors an infinitely
large set of vectors
v
i'm calling that i'm going to call that
a subset of rn which means it's just
some you know it's it could be all of
these vectors and i'll talk about in a
second or it could be some subset of
these vectors maybe it's all of them but
one particular vector and in order for
this v to be a subset to be a subspace
is some subset of it it could be all of
r n i'll show that in a second but let's
just call let's just say this is v
v is a subset of vectors
is a subset of vectors now in order for
v to be a subspace and this is a
definition
in order if v is a sub v is a subspace
or linear subspace of r n
of r n
this means this is my definition
this means three things this means that
v contains the zero vector
v
contains
i'll do it really that's the zero vector
or you could almost you could you know
this is equal to
zero all the way and you have n zeros so
v contains the zero vector and this is a
big v right there
if we have some vector x in v so let me
write this so it's x
if my vector x
is in
v is in is you know if x is one of these
vectors that's included in my v then
when i multiply x times any member of
the reals so
if x is in v then if v is a subspace of
r n then x
times any scalar
x times any scalar is also
in v
this has to be the case and for those of
you who are familiar with the term this
this term is called closure if i have
any element of a set and i this is
closure under multiplication let me
write that down
and do a new color this is closure
closure
under
scalar multiplication scalar
multiplication
and that's just a fancy way of saying
look if i take
some member of my set if i take some
member of my set and i multiply it by
some scalar and i multiply it by some
scalar i'm still going to be in my set
if i multiply it by some scalar and i
end up outside of my set if i ended up
in some
with some other vector that's not
included in my subset then this wouldn't
be a subspace in order for it to be
subspace for any if i multiply
any vector in my sub in my subset by a
real scalar i'm defining the subspace
over real numbers if i multiply it by
any real number i should also get
another member of this subset so this is
one of the requirements and then the
other requirement is if i take if i take
two vectors in my let's say i have
vector a it's in here and i have vector
b in here
so if if a so this is my other
requirement for v being a subspace if a
is in a sorry if a vector a is in my set
v and vector b
is in my
set v
then if v is a subspace of r n that
tells me that a
a and b
must be
in v as well so this is closure under
addition let me write that down
closure
closure
under addition
once again just a very fancy way of
saying look if i if you give me two
elements that's in my subset and if i
add them to each other these could be
any two arbitrary elements in my subset
and i add them to each other i'm going
to get another element in my subset
that's what closure under addition means
that when you add two vectors in your
set you still end up with another vector
in your set you don't somehow end up
with a vector that's outside of your set
so if you if you if i have a subset of
rn so some subset of vectors of rn that
contains the zero vector
contains a zero vector and it's closed
under multiplication and addition then i
have a subspace so subspace implies all
of these things and all of these things
imply
a subspace this is the definition
of a subspace now this might seem all
abstract to you right now so let's do a
couple of examples and i don't know if
this can examples will make it any more
concrete but i think if we do it enough
you'll kind of get the intuitive sense
of what a space implies
i mean
well let me just do some examples
because i want to stay relatively
mathematically formal
so let's just say i have the the almost
trivially basic set let's let's say my
set of vectors i only have one vector in
it and i have the zero vector so i'll
just do a really bold zero there or i
could write it like this the only vector
in my set is the zero vector
and let's say we're talking about
r3 so let's say my zero vector in r3
looks like that so what i want to know
is is my set v
is v
a subspace
subspace
of
r
3.
well in order for it to be a subspace
three conditions it has to contain the
zero vector
well the only thing it does contain is
the zero vector so it definitely
contains the zero vector so zero vector
check
now is it closed under multiplication so
that means if i take any member of the
set there's only one of them and i
multiply it by any scalar i should get
another member of the set or i should
get maybe itself so if let's see there's
only one member of the set
so the one member of set of the set is
the zero vector if i multiply times any
scalar what am i going to get i'm gonna
get c times
c times zero which is zero c times zero
which is zero and c times zero so it's
gonna i'm gonna get the it's only member
but it is closed so it is closed
under
multiplication under multiplication you
can multiply this one vector
times any scalar and you're just going
to get this vector again so you're going
to end up being in your your your zero
vector set you're going to so you're
that's a check now is it closed under
addition
well clearly if i add any member of this
set to itself or i mean there's only one
member or to another member of the set
there's only one option here if i just
add that to that
what do i get i just get that
i just get it again so it definitely is
closed
closed under
addition
addition
check so it does turn out that this
trivially basic subset of r3 that just
contains the zero vector it is a
subspace it is a subspace maybe a
trivially simple subspace but it
satisfies our constraints of a subspace
you can't do anything with the vectors
in it they'll somehow get you out of
that subspace or at least if you're
dealing with scalar multiplication or
addition now let me do one that maybe
maybe the idea will be a little clearer
if i show you an example of something
that is not a subspace
so let me get my coordinate axes over
here
so let's say i were to find
some subspace
let me some subset i don't know whether
it's a subspace let me call my
set
s
and it equals
it equals all the vectors it equals all
the vectors
and let me say
x1 x2
that are a member
of r2
such that i'm going to make a little
constraint here such that
x1
x1
is greater than or equal to 0.
so it contains all of the vectors in r
and r2 that that are at least 0 or
greater for the first term so if we were
to graph that here
what do you get we can get anything we
can move up or down in any direction
right so all we can go up and down in
any direction but we're constraining
ourselves these are all going to be zero
or greater
so all of these first coordinates are
going to be zero or greater so we're
going to and this one we can go up and
down arbitrarily so we're essentially
this sub this subset of r two r r2 is my
entire cartesian plane
but this subset of r2 would include
the vertical axis
often referred to as the y-axis it will
include the vertical axis
and essentially the first and fourth
quadrants if you remember your quadrant
labeling so that's the first quadrant
and that's the fourth quadrant
so my question to you is is s
is s
a subspace subspace
of
r2
so the first question does it contain
the zero vector so in the case of r2
does it contain
does it contain
0 0
well sure it includes zero zeros right
there we included we said x is greater
than or equal to zero so this could be
zero and obviously there's no constraint
on this so definitely the zero zero
vector is definitely contained in our
set s
so that that is a check
now let's try another one if i add any
two vectors in the set is that going to
be
a third is that also going to show up in
our set well let me just do a couple of
examples maybe this isn't a proof let's
see if i add that vector
to that vector what am i going to get if
i put this up here i'm going to get that
vector if i add
that vector
to that vector what am i going to get i
could put this one has tail i would get
a vector that looks like
i would get a vector that looks like
that and if i did it any if i did it
formally
if i add
let's say that i have two vectors that
are member of our set so let's say the
first one is a b
and i add it to
c
d
what do i get i get a plus c
over this was a d
over b
plus d
so this thing is going to be greater
than zero this thing is also going to be
greater than zero that was my
requirement for being in the set so if
both of these are greater than zero and
we add them to each other this thing is
also going to be greater than zero and
we don't care what these these can be
anything i didn't put any constraints on
the on the second on the second
component of my vector so it does seem
like it is closed under addition
closed
under
addition
now what about scalar multiplication
let's take a particular case here
let me just well let's just take let's
say let's take my a b again
i have my vector
a b
now i can pick any real scalar remember
it doesn't you know so any real scalar
or what if i just multiply it by minus
one
so minus one
so if i multiply it by minus one i get
minus a
minus b
so if i were to draw it visually
if this is you know let's say a b was
the vector 2 4 so it's like this
when i multiply it by minus 1 what do i
get i get minus a minus a minus b i get
this vector
which you can clear visually clearly see
falls out of if we view these as kind of
position vectors it falls out of our
subspace or if you just view it not even
visually if you just do it
mathematically clearly if this is
positive
then this is going to and let's say that
we assume this is positive and
definitely not zero so it's definitely a
positive number so this is definitely
going to be a negative number
so when we multiplied it by negative one
for for really any element of this that
doesn't have a zero there you're going
to end up with something that falls out
of it right this is not a member of this
set because
to be a member of the set your first
component had to be greater than zero
this first component is less than 0. so
this subset that i drew out here the
subset of r2 is not a subspace because
it's not closed under multiplication or
scalar multiplication not
closed
under
scalar
multiplication
not closed so this is not
not a subspace
not a subspace of r
two now i'll ask you one interesting
question what if i ask you just the span
of some
some set of vectors
is that a valid let's say i have the
span of some
let's say
i want to know
the span
of
of yeah i don't know let's say i have
vector v1
v2 and v3 and i'll be you know i'm not
even going to tell you how many elements
each of these vectors have is this a
valid subspace
valid
subspace
of r n where you know n is kind of the
number of elements that each of these
have of
rn well let's pick ed let's pick one of
the elements of let me define let me let
me just call
let me just call u to be the set
uh or is that the set of all linear
combinations of this is the span so let
me just define you to be the span so i
want to know is u a valid subspace so
let's think about it this way let me
just pick out a random element of u
let me pick out a random element of u
actually let me let me
does this contain the zero vector well
sure if we just multiply all of these
times zero that is a so if we just say
zero times v one plus zero times v two
these are all vectors i didn't write
them bold plus zero times v3 we get the
zero vector right we do everything just
is zeroed out so it definitely contains
the zeroed vector this is a linear
combination of those three vectors so
it's included in the span
now what if i let's just let me just
pick some arbitrary
member of of of this span so in order to
be a member of this set it just means
that you can be represented let me just
call the vector x
it means that you can be represented as
a linear combination of these vectors so
you know some combination c1
times v1
plus c2 times v
2
plus c3 times v3
right i'm just representing this vector
x it's a member of this so it can be
represented as a linear combination of
those three vectors
now is this set closed under
multiplication well let's just multiply
this times some arbitrary constant what
is c times x let me scroll down a little
bit
what does c times x equal
let me do a different constant actually
let me multiply times some arbitrary
constant a
what is a
times x well it's a times c1 times v1
i'm just
multiplying both sides of this equation
times a a times c2 times v2
plus a times c3
v
3
right well you could just i mean if this
was an arbitrary constant this you could
just write this as another arbitrary
constant this is another arbitrary
constant and this is another arbitrary
constant and i want to be clear all i
did is i just multiplied both sides of
this equation times a scalar but clearly
this expression right here i mean i
could write this i could rewrite this as
you know c4 times v1 plus c5 times v2
where this is c5 this is c4
plus c6 times v3
this is clearly another linear
combination of these three vectors so
the span is the set of all of the linear
combinations of these three vectors so
clearly this is one of the linear
combinations so it's also included in
the span so this is also in u it's also
in the span of those three vectors so it
is closed
closed
under multiplication under
multiplication
now we just have to show that's closed
under addition and then we know that the
span of i mean i did three here but you
can extend it to an arbitrary n number
of vectors that the span of any set of
vectors is a valid subspace
so let me prove that
so we already defined one x here let me
define another vector that's in u or
that's in the span of these vectors and
it equals i don't know let's say it
equals d1 times v1 plus d2 times
v2 plus d3 times v3
now what is
what is
x
plus y
if i add these two vectors what are the
equal to
well i could just add it
x plus y means all of this stuff plus
all of this stuff
and so what does that equal it means
if you just add these together you get
c1 plus d1 times v
v1 plus c2 plus d2 times v2
plus c3 plus d3 times v3
right i just you know you had a v3 here
you had a v3 there you just add up their
coefficients clearly this is just
another linear combination these are
just constants again that's an arbitrary
constant that's an arbitrary constant
that's an arbitrary constant so this
thing is just a linear combination of v1
v2 and v3 so it must be by definition in
the span of v1 v2 and v3
so we are definitely closed
closed
under
under edition
now you might say hey sal you're saying
that the span of any vector is is is is
a valid subspace but let me let me show
you an example that you know clearly if
i just took the span of one vector let
me just say let me just define u to be
equal to the span
of just the vector let me just do a
really simple one let's say it's just
the vector one
one clearly this can't be a valid
subspace let's think about this visually
so what does a vector one one look like
vector 1 1 looks like this
right and the span of vector 1 1 is all
of this is in its standard position the
span of vector 1 1 is all of the linear
combinations of this vector well there's
nothing else to add it to so it's really
just going to be all of the scaled up
and scaled down versions of this so if
you scale it up you get you get things
that look that look more like that if
you scale it down you get things that
look more like that if you go into the
negative domain so with just by
multiplying this vector times different
values and if you were to graph put them
all into a standard position you would
essentially get a line
that looks like that
you say gee you know that doesn't look
like a whole subspace
but a couple of things clearly it
contains the vector zero it contains the
zero vector we can just multiply
zero times one
we can just scale it by zero
right the span is just all of the
different scales of this and if there
are other vectors you would add it to
those as well but this is clearly going
to be the zero vector so it contains the
zero vector is it is it closed under
multiplication well the span is the set
of all of all of the vectors where if
you take all of the real numbers for c
and you multiply it times 1 1 that is
the span so clearly you multiply this
times anything it's going to equal
another
thing that's definitely in your span
now the last thing is it closed under
addition is it closed under addition
so any two vectors
in the span could let's say that i have
one vector a that's in my span i can
represent it as
c one
some scalar times my
vector there and then i have another
vector b and i can represent it with c2
times
my one vector in my set right there
and so what is this going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
this is essentially going to be equal to
c well let me
get a little more space this is going to
be equal to c1 plus c2
times my vector
right this is almost trivially obvious
but clearly this is in the span it's
just a scaled up version of this this is
in the span it's in a scaled up version
of this and this is also going to be in
the span of this vector because it's
just a this is just another scalar we
could call that c3 and if you just do it
visually
you know if i take this vector right
there
let's say i take that vector and i were
to add it to
and i were added to this vector
if you put them head to tails you would
end up with
you would end up with this vector right
there in green i don't know if you can
see it maybe i'll do it in maybe i'll do
it in red right there you end up in you
will end up with that vector and you
could do that any vector plus any other
vector on this line is going to equal
another vector on this line any vector
on this line multiplied by some scalar
is just going to be another vector on
this line so you're closed under you're
closed under multiplication you're
closed under addition and you include
and you include the zero vector so even
this trivially simple span
was
is a valid subspace and that just backs
up the idea that we showed here that in
general i mean i could have just made
this a set of n vectors
right i picked three vectors right here
but it could have been n vectors and i
could have used the same argument that
the span of n vectors
is a valid subspace of rn and i showed
it right there